normalmente mi capita ha l'ingrato
compito di essere l'ultima speaker prima
del pranzo non mi era mai capitato di
essere l'ultima prima della buonanotte
ma vediamo come me la cavo siamo stati
ovunque in questa serata
siamo stati dentro ospedali siano stati
in posti lontani perfino nello spazio e
io mi occuperò di una cosa molto più
umile che però ci tocca tutti in maniera
veramente molto diretta che è la nostra
capacità di comunicare attraverso la
parola e io in tutti i lavori che faccio
o questo denominatore comune che è la
parola anzi parola in più lingue ma su
questo caso mai tornerò e quindi capite
che non è solo una questione di lavoro
ma una questione di passione io nuoto
dentro al fiume della lingua anzi nuoto
dentro a fiumi di più lingue
ora la lingua non è solo un accessorio
nostro per l'esattezza come ci ricordano
anceschi in un'intervista in realtà
molto comica che lui ha concesso a aligi
che è il rapper inventato da sacha baron
cohen si dice una cosa molto importante
la lingua è la proprietà nucleare che ci
rende umani siamo gli unici animali
sulla fanciulla su tutto il pianeta che
hanno questa capacità cioè di comunicare
attraverso la parola
se voi avete degli animali per casa
sapete che non è vero che il cane faccia
bau e il gatto faccia mia oh
in realtà il cane a tanti bau diversi e
il gatto a tanti milano diversi ma non
esiste nessun altro animale che ha la
competenza linguistica cioè la
possibilità di esprimere il suo pensiero
le sue le idee e le cose che ha in mente
con la precisione semantica dell'essere
umano
la lingua a una serie di caratteristiche
particolari forse quella più difficile
da capire o da apprezzare o forse da
considerare come una cosa positiva è che
le lingue sono vive ogni lingua e come
un animale innanzi un grosso animale
direi che si muove di continuo
cioè rispetto alla lingua che io ho
studiato a scuola oggi l'italiano è già
cambiato allora quando io nella mia
testa penso al italiano penso a una di
quelle creature magiche inventate da
miyazaki non se avete mai visto qualche
anime di hayao miyazaki ad esempio certo
toro che è un grosso animale peloso con
gli occhi molto buoni ecco la lingua
italiana un po così è un animale
ingombrante che si muove lentamente che
però ha il guizzo allo sguardo molto
sveglio allora ogni lingua nel suo
muoversi è però regola regolata dalla
norma
la norma apparte essere un ottimo tipo
di pasta se voi guardate la definizione
di treccani ci dice tre cose
fondamentali la prima la capiamo subito
è un insieme di regole questo va da se e
dove ci fermiamo più o meno tutti ma
dice anche altre due cose la definizione
di treccani dice accettato da una
comunità di parlanti cioè la norma non
viene imposta ai parlanti la norma
l'accettiamo noi perché sappiamo che ci
serve per usare quello strumento che ci
identifica come parte di una comunità
cioè noi parlerà siamo italiani anche in
virtù del fatto che parliamo italiano e
che siamo d'accordo per esempio su un
significato da dare alle parole ci
sarebbe da gli sketch interessanti di
aldo giovanni e giacomo da citare ma
purtroppo non c'è tempo ma se vi dico
cadrega forse qualcuno di voi se lo
ricorda la terza cosa è in un
determinato periodo e contesto storico
culturale cioè la norma cambia allora a
me hanno insegnato che l'essere umano
non si arrabbia perché quello lo fanno i
canoni ma si adira forse vi ricordate
che a molti avranno insegnato che si
deve sempre scrivere familiare e che la
ginsburg era un po strana perché aveva
scritto familiare col g l se voi aprite
una grammatica oggi ho anche un
vocabolario scoprirete che non c'è
nessuna differenza di significato tra
familiare e familiare e che entrambe le
forme sono considerate assolutamente
corrette come obiettivo è obiettivo
questi sono esempi di cambiamenti molto
quasi ci molto semplici ma che segnano
una cosa importante anche la norma
cambia e fra l'altro quello che ci
stupisce dell'italiano è che l'italiano
ha subito dei cambiamenti molto molto
veloci tutti negli ultimi diciamo 50
anni perché fino agli anni 60 cioè fino
all'avvento della tv in sostanza forse
molti ricordano il maestro manzi
non è mai troppo tardi ecco fino ad
allora l'italiano è stato come un
bellissimo cappotto in naftalina nessuno
lo parlava di fatto considerate che nel
momento dell'unità d'italia le stime più
ottimistiche davano il 10 per cento di
italofoni gli altri se la cavavano col
dialetto e questo cosa vuol dire vuol
dire che di fatto l'italiano è potuto
conservarsi uguale a quella norma che
aveva già definito pietro bembo nel
cinquecento peraltro una cosa molto
buffa lui basa la norma no della frode
da volgar lingua sulle tre corone di due
secoli prima
quindi lui fa un'operazione molto
vintage come se oggi luca serianni che
ha il nostro quinto dan cintura nera
diciamo così di grammatica italiana
creasse la sua grammatica pensando a
testi di due secoli fa quindi già la
lingua italiana norma nasce in maniera
strana e continua così cioè di italiano
per secoli non è stato la lingua degli
italiani questo ci ha portato un grosso
vantaggio rispetto ad altri paesi noi
leggiamo dante senza nessun problema se
voi decontestualizzate questi tre
famosissimi versi l'incipit della divina
commedia
in fondo potremmo perfino pensare che di
trovarli su un foglietto dei baci
perugina non sarebbe così peregrina la
cosa beh sicuramente non dimostrano di
avere 700 anni quindi questo è il
vantaggio ora se i cambiamenti sono
accaduti tutti insieme
quello che abbiamo oggi è una lingua che
presenta una serie di varietà irregolari
che ci danno anche in qualche modo un po
fastidio
1 la lingua della strada cioè tutti noi
abbiamo studiato un canone linguistico a
scuola credo tutti abbiano
condiviso l'esperienza di leggere non so
a manzoni e poi c'è però una specie di
buco rispetto all'italiano che noi
effettivamente usiamo quando siamo nella
nostra quotidianità
vi faccio un esempio solo nessuno
parlando usa e gli elia una di quelle
cose che noi abbiamo imbalsamato nelle
coniugazioni dei verbi io tu e lì noi
volessi ma tutti noi oggi parlando
usiamo lui anche dove dovremo usare egli
e dove sappiamo che in realtà lui è un
errore
questo è un esempio banale di lingua
della strada se lo sapevo non venivo
rispetto a se lo avessi saputo non sarei
venuto quanti whatsapp andò non si
mettono certo a scrivere se lo avessi
saputo non sarei venuto perché questioni
di sintesi quindi lingua della strada
due i linguaggi giovanili questa orrenda
corruzione no in realtà sono delle
varietà importantissime perché sono
delle varietà che marcano la formazione
dell'individuo e rispetto alle
generazioni precedenti
è normale che i linguaggi giovanili si
costruiscano per rottura e non per
continuità quindi quando arriva il
ragazzino e vi dice una cosa che voi non
capite tipo io quei due lì scippo bene
voi ovviamente se avete più di diciamo
18 anni cadere dal pero e penserete a
rapina invece scippare vuol dire vedere
bene insieme due persone da relationship
ma questo potete google harlow per
verificare ecco allora sentitevi molto
anziani in sostanza
terza cosa la lingua dei social che sono
un po il mio pallino avete capito
ecco le lingue dei social sono un altro
di quegli ambiti in cui noi pensiamo di
vedere la corruzione della lingua e
invece non è così perché è il segno
finale di quello che abbiamo aspettato a
lungo la lingua viene fatta dai parlanti
fra l'altro neanche con delle grandi
novità questa non so quanti lo conoscono
né stato dei placidi cassinesi 962
cristo è scritto con le k quelle che
l'utente medio considera il tipico segno
dei bimbominkia che sono i ragazzini
ovviamente che scrivo
no queste cose strane questa è
l'iscrizione sulla catacomba di
commodilla non si legge molto bene ma
c'è un consiglio fra l'altro molto
attuale non dice il segretario è se vuoi
che una cosa rimanga segreta non è
parlare molto attuale ma è scritta tutta
in maiuscolo
notate come oggi si usa on line per
urlare ed è senza spazi e la famosa
scripps io continua alla latina quella
che oggi usiamo degli hashtag ad esempio
quindi vedete corsi e ricorsi e questo
bimbominkia chi è che scrive così i mesi
questo è giacomo leopardi che nelle sue
lettere
usa queste abbreviazioni alla faccia ed
elmi degli anni in cui è vissuto e
operato
insomma come avrebbe detto tullio de
mauro tutti questi sono segni di una
sana e robusta costituzione
dell'italiano fra lato e tullio de mauro
diceva anche un'altra cosa
l'italiano sta benissimo il problema
sono gli italiani
quindi se noi vogliamo occuparci dello
stato di salute della nostra lingua
non dobbiamo pensare che sia la lingua a
rovinarsi ma casomai cosa possiamo fare
noi utenti
ovviamente tutti questi cambiamenti
spaventano che è normale perché l'essere
umano tende a essere stanziale
quindi l'idea che oggi si possa scrivere
se stesso con l'accento perché in realtà
la l'omissione dell'accento è solo una
falsa regola creata a scuola vi farà
andare in subbuglio vivi indignerà ma di
fatto abbracciato questo tipo di
cambiamenti senza particolare paura
perché sono un segno positivo per la
nostra lingua
allora se noi non abbracciamo il
cambiamento abbiamo delle conseguenze
brutte ci ridiamo la formula a me a
scuola hanno insegnato così è la fine
della conoscenza linguistica ci fa
diventare pedanti o grammar nattino in
certi ambienti si usa l'espressione
campanacci e mi piace anche riesumare
un'antica parola che forse molti di voi
conoscono che è live driss tradotta da
generazioni di studenti come tracotanza
allora il pedante linguistico che
diventa tracotante le cose stanno così
arriva perfino a dire all'accademia
della crusca che la crusca sta
sbagliando perché a me la mia maestra
insegnato in altro modo
stando su twitter questo mi succede di
continuo troppe certezze in sostanza
provocano il blocco della conoscenza
allora cosa bisogna fare per evitare di
bloccarsi
io dico un paio di cose 1 coltivare il
dubbio fecondo in campo linguistico ad
esempio cos'è farsi venire dubbi sulla
pronuncia si dice pur i cockoo dico sì
dice nuoro nuoro più recentemente c'è
stata la polemica si dice bellici o
belice ho scoperto studiando che si dice
belice anche se generazioni sono
cresciute ascoltando in tv la pronuncia
belice perché è una forma di
normalizzazione prima si scrive in
questo modo anche il più colto può avere
dubbi
pensate a guadagniamo scritto conoscenza
lei
questo è un dubbio che moltissimi hanno
beh posso spoilerare il finale e dire
che si scrive con la iii e che ci sono
motivazioni morfologiche valide per
questo e poi in fondo noi conosciamo
bene circa un 20 per cento del lessico
dell'italiano quindi anche il più colto
di noi può incontrare una parola che non
conosce faccio alcuni esempi recenti
l'indignazione per gelicidio considerato
un neologismo datazione 1360 scritta su
un cartello comunissimo di tutti i posti
d'italia divieto di accesso eccetto
frontisti
io da ragazzina pensavo che i frontisti
fossero i reduci della guerra
poi ho scoperto veramente cosa volesse
dire per non parlare di quanti sono
anche i cattolici praticanti che non
sanno spiegare il significato di
transustanziazione a proposito di parole
difficili da pronunciare quindi il
vocabolario perché alla fine chi è
responsabile della salute della propria
lingua e siamo proprio noi la comunità
dei parlanti bisogna ovviamente
rispettare la norma quindi dire che non
esiste più la norma è sbagliato noi
dobbiamo aderire a questa norma ma
sapendo che può cambiare
cioè che non è definitiva anche se a noi
a scuola hanno insegnato in un modo le
cose
possono essere cambiate pensate che ai
tempi di leopardi era normale ad esempio
dire habiba di queste forme che oggi
farebbero pensare esclusivamente a un
personaggio cioè fantozzi il modello
fantozzi bhatti lei se vi ricordate
ecco quindi anche una cosa che una volta
era corretta oggi diventata scorretta
cioè i cambiamenti linguistici sono
veramente molti e molto diversi chiusura
nei confronti delle parole straniere non
siamo mai stati un popolo autarchico non
lo saremo mai ma ovviamente vanno usate
con giudizio mentre una parola come
spoilerare può servire ero anche usata
io ma anche screenshot perché se no devo
fare una lunga circonlocuzione per
spiegare cosa voglio dire
ecco che magari la mission aziendale non
serve oppure la location quindi in
realtà il segreto del forestieri smo e
di usarlo come peperoncino dei piatti
cioè se ne mettete troppo copre tutti
gli altri gusti dosare la parola
straniera benissimo divertirsi con le
parole ma solo nel contesto giusto
perché sennò la figuraccia ce la
facciamo noi quattro domande da farci di
continuo una in che contesto mi trovo
fondamentale due che sono interlocutori
ai quali sono i nostri ruoli come il
ragazzetto che i ragazzi del mio
studente che una volta entrato in aula e
mi fa prof
mi dispiace affatto un scusi
le pare la parola giusta in
questo contesto
vabbè prof ma lei è giovane ai cablaggi
eto'o no è una questione di ruoli io
sono nel suo docente quindi tatuaggi o
meno lei in aula l'università
non lo deve usare esempio di contesto
quanto tempo a disposizione il mio sta
finendo quindi sarò molto sintetica però
è fondamentale lo spazio il tempo di non
andare oltre a quello che ci viene dato
perché è una forma di rispetto per gli
altri e infine la cosa fondamentale
quello che sto per dire o scrivere
questo sui social vale il doppio
serve veramente a qualcosa cioè a porta
qualcosa la discussione in corso
io scrivo una poesia e uno sotto
commenta non solo
d'accordo ma problema tuo voglia dire no
tre parole fondamentali mobilità
riflessione
accendiamo lo questo benedetto cervello
3 responsabilità siamo gli unici
responsabili delle parole che usiamo il
cittadino perfetto di oggi in italia è
una persona che conserva il dialetto
perché sono le sue radici parla bene
parla e scrive bene l'italiano perché
gli serve per essere pienamente
cittadino in tutti i sensi di questa
società e parla almeno una lingua
straniera perché ormai siamo in una
situazione globale in cui ignorare che
esiste nelle altre lingue e
assolutamente sciocco e superficiale
quindi la competenza linguistica si deve
costruire per aggiunta e non per
sostituzione e questo grazie al cielo è
sempre possibile perché in realtà non ci
finisce mai lo spazio
l'importante è non fermarsi visto che
siamo nel fiume linguistico l'errore più
grande che possiamo fare è smettere di
nuotare
perché chi si ferma affoga e adesso vi
ringrazio in tutte le lingue che ho il
piacere di conoscere
[Applauso]